well Sandra Muller has been told to pay
some 20,000 euros in fines and damages
after being found to defame the TV
executive who she said had sexually
harassed her now she is known as being
the leader or the starter of the Miche
movement here in France which is called
balanced on Thor which means rat on your
pagan back in 2017 she had tweeted about
an incident for many years before in
which she had said a TV executive who
she went on to name and shame had made
inappropriate advances to her but the TV
executive in question says as a result
of this he was labeled as a sex offender
he received a huge barrage of criticism
on social media and he was unhappy he
said even more so when she rejected his
advances which he admits actually
happened he then went on to apologise
effectively I did make misplaced
comments to Sandra Miller during a
drunken cocktail party very late one
night but only once I liked her I told
her so heavy-handed ly and only once I
must point out I don't want to exonerate
myself from my boorishness at the time I
reiterate my apologies well Sandra Malay
isn't happy with this verdict in the
court neither is her lawyer and both say
that they will now look to appeal I
didn't win the other women Wan I lost
here today but in any case women and all
genders have started talking this
decision doesn't take away from the fact
that women's voices have been liberated
that you must continue to speak out and
you must continue to denounce
reprehensible acts of any kind fear must
not win fear must not change sides well
this isn't perhaps the first
embarrassment for the me2 movement to
think about the Italian actress and
activist Asia Argento who is one of the
four bearers of the me2 movement across
the globe and also a New York professor
Evita
Ronald booth who talked about being
victims of sexually inappropriate
behavior in the past but both women will
later accused by young men of making
them the victims of sexually
inappropriate behavior and many people
have long questioned this idea of naming
and shaming people who are being accused
of being sexual offenders or sexual
predators given that in a public space
such as social media there's often
little to no evidence to back up that
those allegations those claims have got
a real grain of truth to them and many
people saying why didn't you take them
to the courts in the first place and
some saying as a result of that their
careers have also been ruined their
personal lives have also been ruined so
some people questioning now whether this
defamation case marks a real reversal in
the fortunes of the me2 movement not
perhaps just here in France but across
the globe with many other people perhaps
looking at this case and wondering if
they - now could bring their own
defamation case
you